hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm still an unshaven mess but I've
got a very interesting game for you here
called scale now I actually saw this
game Wallas at PAX Prime and from what I
saw it was very interesting and
experimental style game which I love as
you all know I'm very into the indie
game community all my goodness I'm a
doctor
what the hell am I looking at I love the
music Wow I'm sippy okay so I think I'm
in some sort of a cave yeah it's very
stylized in its art direction and
whatnot which is totally what wasn't
good I just see flitting by the left
side of my screen you're gonna explain
that to me no okay hello I like it first
oh I get it this is like a level select
holy crap
that music is awesome by the way I just
have to point that out that music is
freaking amazing
okay memory number one flower up start
start start okie dokie
you
alright it's giving me the same
instructions as before but I seem to not
be in a cave I steamed it whoa aah oh my
feet
I can see my feet in my hands ok
spacebar to jump you take me for some
kind of fool guy stupid head probably
Hey
so the point of this game for what I saw
before is it um you have a device that
allows you to change the size of objects
in oh oh I see it's like one of those
classic valve puzzles where you pick up
an object in you put it down you pick up
an object and put it down you do that
over and over again hey I was kind of
reminding me of getting the can scale
nope I sucked out its scale juice Oh
grody oh I get it
oh ah I see and then I need to shoot my
scale juice at it and then there you go
it's big enough to suck down and maybe
win them across your game oh don't crush
me holy crap ah I found a new toy oh
this is gonna be fun okay I think I know
what I need to do pick it up through the
bars then shoot my juice at it Oh too
much juice added there we go exactly 101
I'm good ah so cool I have an idea I get
on it I can oh yeah what happened oh
well it certainly got big okay this is
why I thought that this was one of the
coolest games
I saw it Paxton oh my god it's so cool
oh it's kale juice I didn't need to
inject my juice into that one oh this is
so cool I can steal the clown
look at all I can only suck so much
juice out of it I'm still getting there
we go it's temporarily blocked yeah yeah
I don't know what's up with those but
hey do I seem a bit maniacal right now
because it's just ridiculously cool okay
oh so cool Wow looks like it has a die
on I am getting way too excited about
this
oh that's so cool then I can yeah no I
can't I need to wait no I need to shrink
it down first get on this side of it oh
ah oh I made it okay all right we got a
treasure chest
rotate thing II to pick up I wanna wait
rotate thing ooh can I dump out its
contents ah oh no fine whatever then
fine be that way okay Oh am I gonna cool
I want that I need to get that whatever
that is I need it there's some kind of
momentum ah whoa
I got a gem whoa particle get I'm wait
what we know I wanted to play in that
world No I wanted to play fine I'll move
on to the next level this is just an
alpha this game is currently on
Kickstarter right now it's got a few
days left but uh I'm hoping that by the
end of this I can convince you that this
game is kind of Awesome which it is Oh
way too much fun
so basically the whole concept is just
sucking and injecting scale juices dirty
and raunchy as that sounds it's totally
fine though whoa
that is a big-ass tree it was huge it
was so big Wow where did it go one of
those things can I make those big oh my
god oh it's got a butt oh boy
you see I can't get away from me
Hey stop being so terrifying I'm gonna
shrink you down and enfant estimate good
ha ha ha ha
oh it's being blocked by the clouds eh
Oh drink the clouds down get him out
here get him out of here be more scale
juice for my monster oh I made it too
big it's not often you come across a
game that has like a unique mechanic to
it that's never been seen in other games
or maybe this is getting mechanic has
been seeing another games I just haven't
played them but oh I'm so tickled waggly
but wibbly-wobbly Willy Willy woo give
me here whoa I can't whoa how much
bigger could it get I need to shrink
down the no no nope boy boy boy I don't
know what happened to the other one I
shrank down I think that this green dot
is it over there but all right funs over
oh I can't even drink it anymore I think
it's stuck oh there goes okay fine I got
plenty of scale juice anyway don't know
I need your stupid juices this is so
cool
well I don't even know what the story is
behind this like why am i sucking this
algae's where did this gun come from oh
I don't know oh really no oh wait I was
on the same level I didn't even realize
those on the same level that's insanity
but I guess I was holy crap okay there
we go then
alrighty then so what else does there to
this level whoosh
besides this big-ass hole here huh
literally uh-huh
what's he gonna do to me if I get too
close - why is he ah oh no my framerate
tanks and you're going back down hmm oh
what's this oh you want to eat me out
hate me
wasn't that big oh I know what I need to
do I need to get inside of it I thought
I saw I thought I saw like I see a glowy
glue in there so he's got to be big
enough I got to get up there something
get stuck on that and hang on I need
this tree come here come here come here
come here come here I need you because I
need to stand on your branches to be
able to get up here no come on WOB right
with me there we go
alright now you you stop looking at me
so stupidly stop being such a doofus now
open your mouth oh don't get stuck there
open your mouth do I have to go in
through your but it ain't me woops all
right I got him they're gonna work this
out better that's why the name of the
level was good it wasn't that old
Nickelodeon show that I really liked
no it was oh wait there's already uh
there's already a conveniently placed
ledge over huh oh yeah let me just lure
him over here actually let me just pick
up the guy that I need and bring him
over cuz they seem pretty docile when
they're smaller
alright you with your butthole how about
you seem to be able to place them in
midair
maybe I could just do that Oh what am I
looking at
what is it doing with the get away from
me you're freaky Terry okay so what's
gonna happen is I'm gonna get up on this
ledge thing and I'm gonna make it
no big Oh what the hell what this isn't
a real ledge Oh God in the frame rain
tank remember this is an early alpha
build there's gonna be some Oh
oh good golly there's gonna be some
instability on the test version of it
and looking at those guys is not a good
idea what is going on I think those guys
colliding or taking my framerate god
damn it uh-oh
what is happening oh it cleared up what
happened what happened here I see you in
there just come here come here
stop colliding with objects okay this is
a little unstable I'm gonna go to the
hub there I have no idea I have no idea
but this is one open now per pound
okay let's try this old Victorian house
ception we got it
why do they call these memories that's a
pretty tree I really like the pixelated
style of it oh I get it I know what I
need to do I need to get in the house oh
so cool is there a house inside this
house
it's how why you said house Duchin oh
boy no I want to want to make this house
bigger and then I'm gonna oh whoa whoa
what happened now I won't be able to I
got to go outside I gotta go outside
damn it I was hoping to be able to do
that but can't get it big enough she
said oh good golly I made it too big
that's what she said
I didn't exactly make an extensive yeah
you come yeah you'll go over here we
shrink down and go over there I need to
deal with this excuse me upon me thank
you
all right no you it'll hear once again I
gotta say I really like the music of
this game atmospherically this game is
very nicely earned very nicely made
I mean graphically it may seem
simplistic but actually the stylized the
stylization of it makes us nothing
special in my opinion my opinion I am
just a humble let's player but I'd like
to go oh
oh I know what I need to do I need to
bring the other house in here oh oh oh
you saucy makes you oh not manga mix you
know mixes in never mind you wouldn't
understand what oh there we go
yeah Lebowski oh yeah
particle gay high five I'm the only one
here so it's kind of sad to go home I
still I still in shaving I'm I'm out
scraggly mess I I don't even think I'm
gonna continue with the no Shave
November thing because it is quite
disgusting if I do say so myself
okay so I need one more to get into the
other levels and hopefully butterfly
ride oh wait a minute you're kind of
scary when you're bigger that's what she
said wait no it's in there what do I
need to do to get it and scale wait no
ah what and you say Oh what I would I
would I think I messed that one up okay
anyway let's get back to the butterfly
ride I know there's a butterfly that's
gonna be going on over there
oh oh I know what I need to do I need to
I need to hop on this so that when I
make I can make the butterfly bigger
from a distance and then I can Oh indeed
but it works alright we're going for a
ride no get away from the flower get
away from the flower okay there we go
yeah yeah go for that flower over there
it's a big in hey oh it's a cheap damn
it get out of the way other butterfly
how about if I dingus oh I almost fell
off the butterfly you think you can get
away don't don't start mating oh god it
is okay good so I have to say about that
oh it's so big particle get oh yeah this
game is so cool I'm not even being
sensational about this this game is
really cool
it's puzzles on a whole different level
and I don't know if this is available
for you guys right yet because the game
is still an early alpha and obviously
the full game has not been released
bang bang whoosh but I mean I was lucky
enough because I have a contact with Amy
static Josh Mattingly and he sent me
this overhead oh oh it's so cool cool in
a desert
give me your juices my ceiling you I'm
getting something out of you
whoa wow wow I broke it I broke it I
broke the game I broke my framerate I
broke my computer I broke the game I
broke the game I am going to die up here
I need to get out please go to the hub
oh my god ah don't do whatever I did
remember like I said before game very
still experimental still early stage
still wall the Kings to work out but so
far so good
Oh
and yes this game is on kik sir can I
steal the world that I'm on the can okay
that's might have been what I was doing
before okay so I made the whole world
smaller oh my god I stuck that have
everything yeah that was easy
hang on let me continue playing in that
world because I got that one idea what
was he supposed to get that one that
wasn't even available to me okay I don't
know if this game is voxel-based and if
you know anything about like certain
things and things maybe voxels you know
vassals up okay now is there a zero one
at the top of this thing well snowman
the table is no tangy to look kind of
like a penis but not gonna mention that
oh I already mentioned it Oh
live on the air oh no oh no and a good
oh well whatever okay that particle has
been guy about on the clouds how am I
supposed to know where our particle is
how am I supposed to know how am I gonna
know where a particle is have you down
the canyon I would say anything then
again I don't know if I'm even able to
see anything down here
okay um I'm in the canyon I don't know
what I'm doing this is totally just
messing with my mind at what can be done
that's maniacally awesome maniacally
awesome okay so I'm under the Isola got
a cave
oh no okay wait you gotta be careful
with this there's a cave in here I want
to get in it's got a jumping jump and
shoot it's kind of job of shooting
jumpers shooting jumpers shoot okay can
I get in here now
ooh oh no wait where's this what is this
there's nothing can I kill myself by
squeezing it down on top of my head I
don't know damn it didn't do nothing for
me
i'ma do is I'm gonna try to get over to
God the scaling is so messing with my
head I'm gonna get over here oh oh no
there's nothing I thought I saw
something well I'm lost I'm gonna get on
top of the big stone penis and then make
the world bigger I'm gonna make it stuff
yeah yeah make up your own jokes there I
don't even need to I don't even need to
do anything for you if you can't come up
with your own hilarious jokes about that
one well then there's really no hope for
you okay so I'm gonna go back to the hub
and try this one last world because I
don't know how much longer I'm gonna be
playing this but I mean I'm having fun
are you guys having fun watching me you
having fun via proxy living vicariously
through me that's what you guys do right
the Geo dome I need to get six to open
that big door at the end of the hallway
oh wow okay so there's a lot of options
over here I see one I think that's what
they're referring to this kind of
reminds me of Super Mario 64 in terms of
the style the worlds and collecting
stars which is really I really like it
no got a maybe bigger whoa oh whoa I
almost did not make that okay so I need
to get you come here I'm gonna make you
big inator
okay God you suck the juices out of you
then oh how do I wait no I need another
object whoa give me another one what oh
I know what I need to do I know what I
need I need the place is close enough
there so that when I am big inator it
and then I'm shrink-inator it I can
still pick it up
Oh what no oh it's gonna be good maybe I
guess it's gotta make it smaller ah I
know it ah such a genius Oh what what
what's that what's it
oh I'm a genius yeah particle again okay
I'm gonna get one more level try to open
that big door and see what I can do
wait no that wasn't it ah the geode Oh
must be the thing with the dirt on the
top of it I guess no we get over there
how do i oh I don't know if this is
gonna work
yes this is gonna work it didn't work
how do i how do I do
how am I supposed to do okay I know
I know how to do this you can't pick up
a big flower yes weak piece of junk okay
now stay oh yeah baby oh good golly the
physics is just a little wonky
what did I do
what did I just do I don't know what I
did
oh there's a thingy over there I didn't
even notice that and I don't even know
what that's all about is there a thingy
up there all right whatever
oh come on come on
now yeah what do I do here
oh I gotta make this big Oh Oh tree get
out of here sir cut
dingus dingus yes what is going on here
ah come on go tell me it's blocked it's
right there ah you know what fine
whatever yeah I didn't even want it
anyway
I'm trapped over here sure Oh Oh God
ding dump mother okay trying it again
how about that oh hang on I gotta reset
the level Bing boom okay that that
music's first I liked it but now she's
starting to get repetitive and annoying
like it's mocking me I don't take too
kindly to that I'm trying to get by and
you're just being kind of a douche
you're almost you're pulling a real
weight on me here game no I'm not trying
to make that thing
there we go okay now whoa hey hi that's
not what I wanted but I'll take it
anyway nice don't know what that does
Bing bong I'm guessing that lifted that
up to what end I don't even know
OOP all right now in this way I need to
first shrink this so it doesn't get in
the freaking way of the other one and
then I make this one in Bagan aided and
batos gate got the particle it doesn't
even do like a sensational noise for the
particle but then again early build any
criticisms I had I have right now should
be taken with a grain of salt they may
change at any given moment how you doing
today I'm screwing it up I dropped an
orange
Oh methinks I may have screwed this one
up a bit oh oh whoops I need to reset
this level all right so shrink it from
the front first
that way it'll fall forwards then okay
now it's there no way to get a shrink
head down
what's it hold none besides that it's
caught on something else though
it's gone unlike the edges of the walls
I don't know what to do about that but
maybe if I uh I can get up here and on
top of this one maybe I can get around
it here goes nothing
but what are you talking about I can't
make a bigger a fight oh I can always
shrink up oh man there's this morning's
but who cares about that being I'll wait
I know maybe maybe baby baby baby baby
baby oh I didn't even see those down
there this is gonna make the orange
bigger
Oh what's this giant bridge of an orange
I like the sound of that but that say I
could pick that orange up come on
oh I was right there mother of dingus
balls I screw everything up I touch
everything I touch it's just good I'm
here oranjee there we go all right I'm
gonna find out what by this giant door
here we go yeah we go that's more like
it hope I stay up there we go and push
the button Bing bong Bing bong Bing bong
Bing bong Bing bong Bing bong
well alright
thanks for play here's a low framerate
Oh God Wow whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm gonna
just go back to the up there okay that's
the end that's the end of this demo but
okay all right
final thoughts apparently that is the
end there's more levels that are
mirrored more particles that I could get
but I saw every level available you guys
saw what was here it was pretty awesome
this is a unique and very interesting
way of going about a game I could see so
much potential for expansion in this
idea and it could just go beyond this
this this could be implemented other
game styles just besides exploration and
puzzle solving this is really cool
I love the idea I love the concept the
execution is great I love the stylized
way that you do things um oh no this is
phenomenal I love it performance issues
aside I'm sure everything will be
finalized in the final release does the
Kickstarter for this you can find in the
description I don't know if there's a
playable build for you guys but I was
lucky enough to play it hope you enjoyed
it thank you so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
just a little jump scare from the closet
filled with bars that's better than the
one in I amnesia they had us